hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast Anna I'm checking in on you I'm
just checking in on you I really need to
check in on you at least have for you a
little less than half oh Jesus
make sure you guys alright there's a lot
of crying going on out there
jesus [ __ ] christ I've never seen so
many [ __ ] adults crying in my life
what is with all the [ __ ] crying I
get it your person didn't win but Jesus
Christ you're making the left look
horrible going to Canada I love this
[ __ ] where people like threatening like
cher cher goes if Trump wins I'm gonna
go to Canada it's like who gives a [ __ ]
you know I'd even know you were still
here look I'm not saying I'm happy I
wasn't happy with either one of these
people all right but the level of
[ __ ] arrogance of celebrities during
all of this [ __ ] was just did such a
whole other level do you realize how
[ __ ] arrogant you are that you're
making this you basically you're
threatening that if your candidate
doesn't get in you're going to leave the
country and your ego is so [ __ ] big
you think somebody's going like well I
want to vote for Trump but if he gets
elected we lose share I got you babe the
[ __ ] out of here
Mary Barbra Streisand really you're
gonna leave [ __ ] Malibu to go live in
Manitoba really [ __ ] go ahead and do
it I'll give you 40 bucks for your house
that ought to get you at nine thousand
[ __ ] acres up there go out go go move
up to Yellowknife the dumbest [ __ ]
but I literally think like that's the
level of ego that you have to have as
like an actor a comedian or something
like that literally
- I mean I know I guess I talked about
it but you know I [ __ ] around trash
people I'd never told you guys who to
vote for or whatever I just trash them
both I tried to evenly but that [ __ ]
level that people take it to they just
start uh you know I kind of was I was on
Conan last night which was a really
difficult show to do last night because
you know you know people are like
[ __ ] stunned out here they can't
believe it
as I can't believe it in San Francisco
Berkeley [ __ ] New York City and all
that type of [ __ ] so it was kind of
weird it was like going on like right
after a funeral I felt so um but I
really think this is just my own opinion
what do you guys what do you guys think
about celebrities endorsing a candidate
because I think the candidates they also
kind of reach out to people a little bit
like like I've never understood that
like why would I be like you know who is
some of the people you know some of the
[ __ ] people have done it like I just
don't understand it so oh you know I was
gonna vote this way but the guy from my
three kings told me to do although the
movie where he tries to get the SkyMiles
the guy who did the movie about this guy
getting the SkyMiles
is telling me this should be the person
to lead the free world you know I got a
lot of feelings on gun control but let
me check in with Sean Penn first see
what he has to say the level of [ __ ]
arrogance that you have to have I know
it's a fine line cuz it's like alright
well it's good that they're involved
politically but like you know there's a
lot that what's your famous then they're
actually going to put a camera on you
then you're going to start talking you
know it's the same thing it's when you
become a huge fan of your teacher your
big fan of your team right and you know
you're always sitting up in the
nosebleeds and then all of a sudden you
get a part on a sitcom and then they got
you sitting down there and then your
team is doing well and next thing you
know they're sticking the microphone in
the face of an actor right to be or not
to be a
do you think Buffalo has to do here in
the second half well I'd like to see you
of your checking down a little bit
slightly I don't I don't understand it
babe I bet you know what in defense of
celebrities regular people do the same
thing on the news and they get away with
it because you don't know what their
names are you see it all the time on
these uh you know when you watch the
news if you ever watch the news they
always go we went out on the street to
ask people what they thought about this
new target that's going up I think it's
gonna take away jobs you know I just
think the downtown area we don't need
that there's always that [ __ ] person
right so maybe that's what it is that's
that person is no different than any of
those other people it's just I don't
know I think once you get to a certain
level you kind of need to gracefully
shut the [ __ ] up all right
having said that kinks anybody explain
to me why they're making such a big deal
about the transition of power here as
far as you know we hope that it's going
to be graceful we hope that it's going
to be the wind Obama came in George Bush
was very gracious he was very blood they
all they all were my entire life I've
never you know Reagan did knock on the
White House door and Jimmy was just like
hey get the [ __ ] out a we don't want any
there's literally cameras on that's
another thing too this cameras filming
you as this transition happens everybody
everybody's always you know you're going
to be grace gracious they don't will it
you know they don't like each other you
know this one's going to be particularly
[ __ ] weird
you know considering the sizeable
overtly racist individuals that you know
I don't know what the [ __ ] they were
here but they gravitated towards Trump
so considering you know Barack being the
first black president to now let this
guy into I don't know
according to people I hear it I mean
[ __ ] look that up was endorsed by the
clay
this is just [ __ ] nuts well that's it
that was the end it's the end and now
it's over now everybody can [ __ ] move
on and um you know I got I did Conan
last night I think I think when as well
as it could have have gone and then of
course you know I got people giving me
[ __ ] you know I was trying to say look
whoever's president it's not really
going to affect my [ __ ] day-to-day
then of course yours could you [ __ ]
what god bug with the vibe of it's like
yeah I get it I get it I get it but your
day to day your day to day this is my
and this is supposed to be uplifting by
the way all right
knowing full well that the world isn't
fair okay and that some people start
wave closer to the finish line than
others that's just how it is all right
and there's advantages and disadvantage
just to that you know if you got to run
further you always think that other guy
yeah he's [ __ ] zone all he's got to
do is just [ __ ] go fright from there
to there right and you see all these
[ __ ] rich kids they got drug [ __ ]
problems because they have no worries in
life they [ __ ] rudderless and all
that type of [ __ ] everybody wants to
think if you filthy stinking [ __ ]
rich that you just skip around your life
is [ __ ] awesome I've done enough
corporate gigs to see that there's not a
lot of happiness over there they're
[ __ ] with really rich people I got to
tell you out in Malibu
you know Nia always wants to go out to
Malibu she loves the [ __ ] beach and
we go out there and his [ __ ] you know
the seaside restaurants and [ __ ] you
know what you're cool it's great you
[ __ ] watch people surfing it's
awesome you go out you have a couple of
crab legs and then you get the [ __ ] out
of there but there's a mall over there
all right
the Malibu mall whatever the [ __ ] you go
over there and I'm just telling you the
people over there I cannot put my finger
on it they are [ __ ] weird really rich
people there's there's some sort of
[ __ ] disconnect I don't know what's
going on with them they just they're I I
said to me I go what it what is what the
[ __ ] is with these people there's no
vibe there's no laughing what's going on
in she just she goes they're bored
I think that's what it is I don't I
don't know I did gigs um um way back in
the day I did some gigs out on the
Hamptons another place with like super
rich people and they just [ __ ] weird
they'd sit there and they all look at
each other they're looking you up and
down like I showed up and immediately
they were just like alright this guy's
in here for the day
is it day tripper look at his [ __ ]
sneakers huh look at his [ __ ] orange
afro nobody's red hair makes it in this
world before they met Donald Trump how
the [ __ ] did he go from a brunette to
[ __ ] looking like me in seventh grade
I don't understand it um anyways but
yeah you make your own [ __ ]
opportunity and I think you know is
depressing is that is it I always looked
at that like I don't know I always try
to see like what the [ __ ] I can do I
just can't believe that all the names
that I'm hearing now Jesus Christ Newt
Gingrich Rudy Giuliani these [ __ ]
guys are coming back Jesus Christ that's
like that Stallone movie where he took
all the [ __ ] action heroes from back
in the day Seagal and they all got to
have one last [ __ ] thing unless it's
a head then we'll make like three of
them was that called the [ __ ] last
gladiator Action Hero 2 [ __ ] I don't
know drink your juice in the hood I want
to [ __ ] with the Expendables man this is
like he's bringing beds like the
Republican Expendables he's bringing all
these guys back trying to think of
another classic name he's got to go for
from way back in the day somebody didn't
die I don't know whatever but you know
something it's over get on with your
[ __ ] lives
and you know there's all these protests
at colleges I don't know what they're
protesting I don't quite get it it's
like there was an election it was legal
and your person lost I guess they're
just voicing their displeasure with the
fact that this guy's in there I dude I
cannot [ __ ] believe that the host of
The Apprentice is now present in the
United States and that people are this
excited and hopeful half the country is
excited
and hopeful you don't I mean you know
the most amazing thing ever our
broke-ass people that are Republicans
that's the most amazing [ __ ] thing on
the planet so you guys in guys
he's gonna make it great again for you
all right
please keep checking in on me throughout
the years I want to know how your life
into individually will become great
again or this country will become great
again so then your life will be great
again all those [ __ ] people who will
gallop in sideways I love how he wants
to [ __ ] it he doesn't want to have
health care but he wants to build a
[ __ ] wall
from California to Mexico oh how much
money is that gonna [ __ ] cost live
with the job that's gonna create get a
[ __ ] out of here that's a definite
you know bad all of these [ __ ] you
know something that's one thing that
they'll never police but that [ __ ]
[ __ ] we're these contractors they
get these government jobs to build [ __ ]
and they charge ten times the amount
that they should and these politicians
just throw the [ __ ] money around and
they don't give a [ __ ] or they have to
do it whatever the deal is you know like
the math on this whole thing do you
realize like seven billion dollars was
spent to get somebody a job that pays
500 grand a [ __ ] year you know why
cuz I bet it was I bet it was a bunch of
people that build forms you know
foundations and [ __ ] that's what you
know they were like out man I got to get
that I got it I got to build the wall
man you know some guy with the [ __ ]
rusted out pickup truck dude if I get
that [ __ ] job all our problems are
gonna be over I'll be building that for
the rest of my life um what a [ __ ]
crazy goddamn time
you know everybody wondering how the
[ __ ] this happened I think you know what
it is is people are still digging out of
what happened in 2008 and it would have
been nice if one of these [ __ ] [ __ ]
politicians would have said something
about the [ __ ] bankers you know I
don't know we will see what happens
yeah boy I'll tell you know was great
those when I went to go to the elect to
vote I [ __ ] had I looked through all
the [ __ ] propositions everything I
had all my filled it all out like a
[ __ ] old lady and I went in there and
I was just like bing bang boom boom boom
I blew through the whole thing
knew exactly what I wanted to vote for
actually felt mildly informed this time
so he just showed up in his own [ __ ]
plane this guy's a gangster um literally
we shall see you know what's funny is my
wife had on MSNBC by the way you know
what I was doing during the election I
just kept flipping back and forth to
like who if whoever was losing I would
start watching them I would put on like
CNN you know I played on Fox at first in
the beginning and once they started
looking like they were winning and they
were surprised then I went over to the
CNN thing and then I went down to the
Comedy Store and did Doug Stanhope live
podcast and I that was the most amazing
election I've ever [ __ ] seen oh it was
like reliving for hours it never got
boring and as much as I don't like Trump
I didn't like Hillary either I have to
say watching people crying white people
I want to say white people if I see
somebody of color crying like God Jesus
this is brutal but just somebody white
crying it's like I'm still white in
America there was just something funny
about that to me like people hugging and
stuff blew my mind blew my mind how many
people just still look at Hillary
Clinton like she's not a complete
dishonest piece of [ __ ] and like the
best I could get anybody say is like
yeah but they're all like that um
alright are you guys done I'm done
enough with this [ __ ] alright let's
watch the gracious
the Obamas they were they they shook
hands they were very gracious and this
is what makes the United States the
United States this this peaceful passing
of power this is what makes the Americas
the United States of America's alone I
don't know why this is like such an
amazing [ __ ] thing this is just like
just a different head that's owned by
the same what [ __ ] twenty
corporations out bill with your hacky
conspiracy theory but isn't it isn't
that what it is well isn't it um anyways
let's move on everybody let's move on to
a little bit of bread and circus there
so this guess what just went on sale
everybody as of yesterday promoted on
the Conan show a Conan O'Brien show the
fifth annual Patrice O'Neal comedy
benefit as always at the New York City
Center tickets are already on sale
once we pay for the house all the money
goes to is his mother and his family and
it's been such a great event that we do
every year and and has had an amazing
effect on on people's lives that he
loved it's been a great thing and as
I've said year after year the reason why
we do it every year is because I always
hate when somebody somebody passes and
it's just like you do like that one
[ __ ] benefit like okay here's a sack
of loot I hope this will last you for
the next 60 [ __ ] years um we all love
Patrice so much that we all decided that
we were going to do it every year and
make sure that we continue to take care
of the people that he was taking care of
and the people that he loved so it is it
is a great cause it is 100 percent
honest it's something you can get behind
none of the comedians are going to be
dressed in pink none of that [ __ ] you
know it'll be a it'll be a great thing
and I'm also doing uh the comm come home
benefit with Denis Leary cam neely this
weekend and OH
Jesus of Jesus did [ __ ] Billy
red-faced buy some cigars holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] I've never smoked these before but
I'm not going to tell you where I got
them I'll see you like a picture of him
here I actually left them down in the
[ __ ] humidor there dude why is this
[ __ ] phone so difficult with me a
reality TV show star people with an
orange toupee is now going to be the
leader of the free world that's what you
did then half of the country feels good
about it I can't [ __ ] believe it uh
Jesus you know what it is it's just none
of it is really that funny it's just not
funny the whole thing was just fun how
to [ __ ] hey on the right and the left
people how the [ __ ] did we end up with
those two how did that happen I just
kept thinking back but like all the
[ __ ] candidates just stunk
God they stopped look that cutiepie in
her camel hair coat the [ __ ] is she
doing now are you talking about um sorry
I got on MSNBC here
what the hell's a goddamn camera here
alright there it is there it is okay
it's a [ __ ] it's a blurry goddamn
picture arm all old boy O'Dell I have
[ __ ] I can't read it I took a blurry
picture of it then I thought if i if i
zoom din it would somehow get better um
wait wait wait wait wait sorry sorry
again the [ __ ] is all there it is okay
Oh yo de monterrey not monteri
Siri la jolla apologies to anybody
Latino listen to this 56r engage it's
like a [ __ ] two hours smoke I got a
[ __ ] box of those goddamn things and
I'm bringing it to comics come home and
I'm hoping there's going to be some
cigar smokers there oh it's going to be
such a great event gonna be a great
event so anyways I have not been paying
attention to [ __ ]
I've been editing my new [ __ ] special
and I'm probably going to add another
[ __ ] stand-up date while I'm out here
as I'm waiting for my kitchen to get
done which still is not done it was
supposed to be done by now but then you
know we ran into the cloth wiring so uh
you know and then the place we were
staying at the haunted [ __ ] house the
person who owned it came back so now
we're we're in a hotel and has a little
kitchen right so I keep saying Ania you
know it's [ __ ] hilarious it has this
little kitchen and has pots and pans but
it has no spatula had nothing that you
could [ __ ] cook with it's hilarious
it just had like the pants and sounds
like oh I see that [ __ ] game plan
they're gonna act like there's a kitchen
and then I couldn't give me any [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know they're gonna have a
couple of props this looks like a
goddamn like sitcom kitchen they got a
couple of glasses up front and then
there's like nothing else even like the
cereal bowls are like so [ __ ] shallow
it's like a it's like a deep plate you
know you pour a little bit of milk and
it's already going over the sides so I
drove back to my house and got all my
[ __ ] tongs and spatulas and all that
type of [ __ ] and now viewing it like um
I'm gonna try to beat them at their own
game right cuz you know stay in hotels
[ __ ] expensive right
Sonia keeps one an order goddamn room
service and I keep saying - I was like
Nia everytime we eat in the kitchen
alright the terrorists loose okay this
this is a victory for us I [ __ ] I've
not enjoyed food the way I have when
you're in a [ __ ] hotel and you
actually buy food you know and start
cooking up and made eggs the other day
right simple [ __ ] just filling myself up
I still got that [ __ ] elk that Rogan
gave me you know I made a little
American chop suey with that [ __ ] and I
don't why why she's telling me let's go
downstairs I'll meet you downstairs you
know they just love like women are
hilarious they just love that hold the
whole scene right oh they got like a
fountain down there and you said in a
sunny area they are like a little tent
it's nice why don't you want to come
oh they just wear you down you just like
Kris it's like [ __ ] nine million
dollars for [ __ ] eggs I know but it's
nice oh [ __ ]
alright fine alright here we go the NHL
this without trying to get - we got the
Columbus Blue Jackets over here the
Boston Bruins maybe I could finally
watch a [ __ ] game you know maybe you
had the [ __ ] NHL Network here's
something I don't [ __ ] know I don't
know the [ __ ] on our team all I know
is our first line as far as I remember
was Marshawn Bergy and posture Duncan I
don't know what the [ __ ] else is on the
thing
Bruins forwards deem or no idea patrice
bergeron back as we had last year David
Krejci Brad Marchand molesky's back Nash
I don't know who the [ __ ] that is Jimmy
Jimmy Hayes Ryan Spota T shalour no idea
posture knock Cesare nicht czar Nick no
idea and I don't know anybody else
someone get Milla Chara McQuaid okay
both Miller's the crew Krug's batboat
billers it back Krug's back McQuaid
Chara better I'll do we never [ __ ]
recovered man whatever that [ __ ] move
was to free up all the salary cap money
when we just basically imploded the team
with two years into this [ __ ] I don't
know it just seems like it's this is
it's the same as like last year as far
as like the level that we're at where
we're going to know Joe Barton ik said
it best he goes you did the worst
[ __ ] thing you could do is you you
you missed the playoffs on the last day
so you lost all the playoff revenue and
then you're gonna be and you're not
going to be you didn't suck so you could
be like [ __ ] you know Toronto and
have a shot at someone like Austin
Matthews you know whatever the [ __ ] you
gonna do as long as the Canadians don't
win it I'm happy I'm a happy happy
[ __ ] guy alright let's read a little
bit advertising here and then I'm going
to give you my predictions for a trump
presidency what's going to change how
he's going to make it great he's gonna
make it great again alright a legacy box
everybody this is this is the greatest
[ __ ] in the world
the legacy box no legacy is like passed
down right he's a legacy all right when
was the last time you watched home
movies your home movies if you're like
most Americans as a box in your closet
of videotapes film reels and photos that
don't get watched too taken out worse
they are actually deteriorating
introducing legacy box a simple and
affordable way to get your recorded
moments digitally preserved on a DVD or
thumb drive here's how it works load
legacy box with your old tapes films
pictures and Auto audio recordings and
send it back you'll get them back in a
couple of weeks on DVD or a convenient
thumb drive ready to watch share and
relive that's pretty cool just make sure
if you did a personal porno you don't
accidentally send that legacy box takes
care of everything it provides updates
at every step of the process that's why
over 250,000 families have used them The
Huffington Post boo Parents magazine USA
Today and the view are all talking about
legacy box even Disney has trusted
legacy box to digitize their media and
for a limited time go to legacy box calm
slash bird to get 40% discount on your
water that's legacy box calm / / one
more time legacy box calm / / with
everyone gathered for the holidays now
is the perfect time to share all those
old photos and cassettes and home videos
go to legs we got it lazy box.com / burn
it 40% off you [ __ ] discount on your
legacy box did I mention its legacy box
alright Joe Rogan's company everybody on
it on it has a new product is called
emulsified MCT oil MCT oil is one of the
fastest sources of clean fuel for the
body in the brain it's one of the best
ways to power up your performance a
kickstart a weight management program
there's lots of MCT oil brands out there
are there I've never heard of it but
there's none emulsify none not like a
multiplied MCT oil from on it available
in three delicious flavors the Billy red
face flavors coconut vanilla and
strawberry coconut head vanilla skin
strawberry pubes emulsified MCT oil
mixes like a cream easily in your
morning coffee without the need for a
blender no mess no cleanup you can even
mix it into your favorite foods right
now if you go to audit comm / / you can
get on its emulsified MC t oil for 12%
off that's on it o n n IM / build to get
emulsified MCT oil for 12% off and for
any reason if you don't like it they'll
give you your money back no questions
asked at axe - asked you've got nothing
to lose go - on it calm now and get on
it alright oh jesus one of our favorite
look who's back it's old zip are you
hiring well are you do you know where to
post your job to find the best
candidates posting your job in one place
while that isn't enough to find quality
candidates if you want to find the
perfect hire you need to post your job
on all the job sites and now you can
with zip brewed up calm you can post
your job 200 plus job sites including
social media networks like Facebook and
Twitter all with the single click find
candidates in any city or industry
nationwide just post once and watch them
your qualified candidates roll into zip
recruit is easy to use interface no
juggling emails or calls to your office
quickly screen the candidate radom and
hire the person fast find out today why
is it ah
runa has been used by over 1 million
businesses and right now my listeners
can post jobs digit
Hey for free by going to zip recruit
accom / / that zip recruiter calm / /
one more time hey zip recruiter calm / /
alright I guess we got a few more to go
here but let's uh I'll break him up here
you know again there's no [ __ ] way
you want to listen to me do six of these
in a row um breaking news Trump and
Obama meeting at the White House this
[ __ ] lady who's moving her [ __ ]
arms around talking talking talking shut
the f--- I mean I got a lot of nerve
telling people to shut up um this is you
know something this is gonna be this is
gonna why is the right so [ __ ] crazy
what is wrong with you guys Jesus Christ
you picked a reality show TV star that's
what the [ __ ] you picked then you picked
george w bush and jericho chi-chan can
you give me a guy you know this is what
kills me about you dumb [ __ ] over there
I I lean right a lot I lean left -
sometimes I'm liberal sometimes I'm
conservative but for [ __ ] sakes can you
get me a guy they could give a speech
you haven't done it since Herbert Walker
Bush he gave a great speech I like that
guy I had no [ __ ] beef with that guy
now I'm gonna go from Josh hacker check
a check for [ __ ] eight years right I
didn't like everything that Obama did
but you got it you have to admit even
you [ __ ] racist [ __ ] got to admit
that guy was phenomenal speaker
phenomenal speaker he's [ __ ]
hilarious he wasn't an embarrassment to
hear the world talk and now we're gonna
have [ __ ] Trump Jesus Christ those of
Juvia humbly I got a lot of nerve
because I actually like Bernie Sanders
watching that guy give a speech Jesus
Christ it was like he was at a town
meeting uh-uh
regarde [ __ ] hands flapping all over
the place you know what I don't know if
there was there wasn't a right choice in
this one there really wasn't all right
now the Marines look it up most of the
two best guys in the world
how do they gotta have snot how the [ __ ]
do they do that will they face each
other they pause for a second right and
then they at the same time they both
[ __ ] out they salute you know what I
mean it's like you ever listen to Led
Zeppelin and then they do it they all
just [ __ ] they're playing they're
playing and then the song just stops and
then they come back in again and
sometimes it's on time sometimes it
isn't it's because you know somebody
just yet it's a look they give somebody
look at that bump you look at these
[ __ ] Marines that they don't give
each other look they still brought their
[ __ ] hand up at the same time there's
got to be some sort of some sort of
marine a little wiggle with an eyebrow
granted we are like 40 yards away with
the camera and then I'm sitting in a
[ __ ] hotel room I wonder what the
[ __ ] audition was to get that gig you
know how many [ __ ] doors did you have
to open like perfectly to be there yeah
it's got to be some proud mom out there
that's my son he's gonna open the door
what was the last time a president with
the toupee was president they've all had
full heads of hair all had full heads of
hair hey ladies who's gonna be the next
lady president I mean the next the first
one I should say do you think Hillary's
done do you think she has enough pant
suits for another run you know I don't
know I just hope she goes to a
chiropractor and gets her [ __ ] neck
fixed cuz I don't know she was like a
baby you know I you [ __ ] you know
babies can't hold their heads up she
kind of was [ __ ] flopping all around
um I love the pantsuit though you know
what I mean if I was a [ __ ] chick of
a certain age you know what I mean I had
the kids already you know shut down the
park if you know what I mean you know
hot flashes are over right Wally world's
closed for renovations you know then you
get got a rock the [ __ ] pantsuit
you got to get the shorter [ __ ] hair
like I don't give a [ __ ] anymore
you know my husband's old what's he
gonna do he ain't going anywhere and you
go out right
you get the Ellen DeGeneres haircut you
go out you get a [ __ ] pantsuit walk
around some flatties for once in your
life you [ __ ] concerned about your own
comfort you know man you know what if I
was Hillary my next [ __ ] move is your
much Johnny Carson had his own line of
[ __ ] sport coats I would have my own
line of [ __ ] pants suits right but
you get people like Rihanna people in
the prime of their [ __ ] life they're
like walking around half-naked and they
somehow you know they somehow turn the
pantsuit in who the [ __ ] is is
good-looking enough in their 20s to make
the [ __ ] pantsuit come back you know
I you know I don't mind the pantsuit
when I was coming up but [ __ ] you
know Rhoda Adam Mary Tyler Moore had him
you know what I mean and they were
[ __ ] young broad so sitting there was
a little [ __ ] fireballed [ __ ]
freckled jerk-off and I would I would
watch all of those [ __ ] Charlie's
Angels the label used to wear them
Farrah Fawcett killed the [ __ ] pants
ooh but the pantsuit back then was sort
of like the Dare version of the John
Travolta suit you know what I mean
it was just a bunch of rayon and no
condoms in the 70s and that's that's how
we ended up where we're at that's why
the [ __ ] roads are so goddamn filled
up now Jesus the sound down on MSNBC
right now just looking at the looks on
people's faces I don't know why this
[ __ ] is so funny to me because I am not
thrilled with this guy being president
but seeing people disappointed and
crying on television you know passed
obviously if somebody they loved died or
something like that I don't laugh at
that [ __ ] but like I told you guys way
back in the day when the Biggest Loser
was on and those fat people would just
start crying about how they couldn't
stop eating hamburgers and [ __ ] it just
[ __ ] always I mean I wanted them to
lose weight and [ __ ] but there's just
something there's something [ __ ]
hilarious
about people cry adults crying I don't
know why it's probably me being a
walled-off you know I'm actually I'm not
that [ __ ] walled up walled-off right I
can get choked up with the best of them
but if I did it you know I expect people
to laugh at me
this is when you know you have too much
news coverage I'm sitting here watching
this Marine opening and closing a door
and these [ __ ] nerd guys keep from
the press keep walking in and out of the
shot look at this there's a lady right
now she's backing up to take a picture
with her cell phone of I don't know what
now the Marines opening the door she
walks out you really you know what
there's actually great that she was in
there just to see who the [ __ ] just
walked out of the place was that like
his cousins or something that's such a
weird gig does that mean you're a good
marine but they make you like the
[ __ ] bellhop of the White House I
know at the end of the day I mean you
went through all of that [ __ ]
training you can snap somebody's neck
right can [ __ ] shoot somebody from
200 yards away and then you know watch
what should detail you're gonna open and
close the back door at the White House
and then what now that's it you can be
dressed in your formal so you're gonna
have your whites on and you're just
gonna stand it [ __ ] attention there's
no way that anybody can do that there's
got to be like two hour shifts how long
can you just stand there that [ __ ]
straight yeah but he's also got to be if
some lunatic comes [ __ ] running up
this remember that guy jumped over the
[ __ ] fence and just ran up and he
actually got into the [ __ ] White
House that was unbelievable that's when
I really realized like how not important
the president was you know once again
they don't even lock the door do you
understand that [ __ ] [ __ ] who
jumped over that gate and ran up to the
White House do you realize that that guy
got further into the White House than he
would have got into my house
my doors locked
then he ran down the hall
he gave a head-fake and he broke the
ankles of some Secret Service guy right
like Iverson did the Jordan when he
first came into the league and he
wouldn't you got like he jeez sake
instead of zagged and that was the only
reason why he didn't just [ __ ] get in
there it's really not funny but you know
the fact that nothing happened that's
kind of [ __ ] hilarious chasing this
guy with his pea soup green [ __ ] tie
just pointing all that type of stuff
he's [ __ ] well geez everybody thinks
to make it a point including me why
don't I read the last few these things
here all right wink pronounced wink winc
all right finding a great new wine is
tough that's why I've been telling you
all about our sponsors at Club Debbie at
Club W I wouldn't even vote for Trump
and how they make it so easy to get wine
personalized to your palate and
delivered right to your door and here's
a little update we have for you Club
Debbie oh Jesus what are we gonna do now
country's [ __ ] is now called wink that
spelled winc a new name and an improved
look but here's the important part it's
still the same amazing wine company
introducing you to new wines you'll love
wink works directly with winemakers and
growers from all over the world to
create delicious wine delivered and
deliver it right to your door winks 100%
satisfaction guarantee means if you
don't like a bottle they send you
they'll replace it with the bottle
you'll love no questions asked you don't
just start but you don't just get rid
sent random bottles winks wink is a
personalized wine membership that
recommends wine specifically for you
based on the results of your palate and
Profile quiz you can also rate all of
the wine you receive from wink so they
learn about you with every order and
constantly personalize the wine they
send sign up for wink right now and gain
immediate insider access to the best
fine wine from all over the world find
out for yourself why
yours truly and thousands of other
satisfied wine lovers I don't love wine
I drink whiskey why do they always make
me do that I like booze if you're into
wine drink the [ __ ] wine gives me a
brutal [ __ ] hangover why do you think
they switched it from Club W I always
liked it Club W watch the Cubs they all
loved me but they only loved me when
they win I can't understand it that's
the best part
wink is offering my listeners 20% off
right now when you try when you go to
try wink calm T ry winc calm / / alright
they'll even cover the shipping hey lady
you know you love the wine think about
it you'll get fine wine personalized to
your palate delivered right to your door
try wink and get $20 off and a
complimentary shipping right now when
you go to try wink calm / / that's try
winc calm allright HELOCs hilux you're
unique you don't walk like anyone else
you don't talk like anyone else or sleep
like everyone else so why is your
mattress one size fits all well cuz the
average height is about 5 9 you know
probably that's the reason most part we
all have arms and legs of [ __ ] head
on top and a torso so this you know why
are all bicycles looking the same
alright because that's what you [ __ ]
feet go and your hands go up there and
this you know because it truly cut oh I
I guess I was wrong because a truly
customized mattress will cost you five
to ten thousand bucks until now go to
helix sleep calm answer a few simple
questions and they'll run a 3d
biomechanical model of your body through
the proper actor proprietary algorithms
I don't know they develop with the help
of it will make you a [ __ ] Magnus it
fits your body the result is the most
comfortable mattress you've ever slept
on isn't that right sir sir oh he's
already asleep that's right I have a
random person sleeping in here helix
helix customers report a 30% improvement
in overall sleep quality and for couples
they customize each side of the mattress
your mattress your mattress arrives you
in about a week and shipping is 100%
free that's why everyone from GQ
magazine to Forbes are all talking about
helix sleep you go Juana you have 100
nights to try it out if you don't like
it they'll pick it up for free gross and
give you a 100% refund no questions
asked go to HELOCs leat calm / burrow to
get $50 off your order that's helix
sleep calm / / well my time high HELOCs
sleep calm / / this is the last one oh
the last one I'm going in with a little
song here people to brighten your
spirits
I don't biondi's me undie you elected
Donald Trump boo doo doo doo biondi's me
undies everybody take a dump the nice
and soft like his toupee
yup also dry and you say hey what the
[ __ ] did we just do it was either the
the Klan or the clam ba da ba doo boo
that was your selections this year the
Klan of the clam me undies picture a
world while putting a new pair of
underwear isn't just fresh you're
stepping into a better day
think about it underwear is the first
thing you put on the last thing you take
off unless you were [ __ ] widow why
would you settle for anything less than
the best feeling underwear on the planet
the undies focuses solely on producing
the most comfortable underwear you've
ever experienced well that's what you do
you make underwear what would you be
doing out what else would you be doing
huh making dioramas my friends at me
undies these people I've never hung out
with who are somehow my friends sent me
a few pairs a while back and now I can't
imagine it wearing anything else that is
alike I wear I'm not even wearing them
right now okay but what they semi were
comfortable except for the Greg losing
glue gained his cut all right was riding
up on my Bulls yeah it wasn't even that
I just I just I could not wear them in
front of my wife
she was just dying laughing at me as I
was walking by you know what I should
have done you know that [ __ ] crazy
things at Olympic swimmers do you know
where they bend over and then they just
start [ __ ] moving their arms like
propellers I'm gonna do that next time
put on my [ __ ] my Greg Louganis
right I'm gonna put on my swimming
goggles when my wife is looking I'll put
on one of her [ __ ] head wraps I'm
just going to come out and do that all
right sorry um anyways for price for the
price of two cocktails me undies will
deliver your new favorite pair of
underwear right to your doorstep better
day guarantee try them on and if they're
not the most comfortable best feeling
undies you've ever had that refunds you
and let you keep your last pair for your
first pair for free including the price
is the sweet touch show the sweet
caressing touch of mode al modal a
special fabric made with the
best-in-class raw materials that are
scientifically proven to be three times
softer than cotton these uber cozy
undies are also sold exclusively on me
on these websites website where you'll
enjoy free shipping in the US and Canada
all right here's the call to action
here's the end right here and for a
limited time everyone in my audience
gets 20% off the first order but you
have to go to our special URL me undies
dot-com / / with me undies better day
guarantee you have nothing to lose so
don't wait any longer go to me undies
dot-com / / right now for 20% off your
first order that's me undies comm slash
/ alright uh-huh and that is the that is
the Thursday afternoon podcast and and
that is the election all right it is
over this is the guy that we picked and
just because you know your person didn't
win it doesn't mean you got to yell at
other people all right you know what be
great is everybody if everybody just
sort of stop yelling at each other okay
you know maybe help each other out you
know somebody actually said to me you
know I'm a bomber care is gonna go away
how the [ __ ] am I gonna pay for my meds
and that immediately made me think well
you know what why don't regular people
just pick up the slack you know I don't
know how to [ __ ] to do it to what set
something up or maybe you just help out
one person what if you're in the prime
of your life or your earning power
whatever you know and somebody down the
street needs meds you know what if you
booze a couple less times a [ __ ]
month and you hook them up with some
money to get their meds you save you one
and then you won't be as bloated you
won't be drinking as much boo
why don't just regular people help each
other out instead of waiting for these
[ __ ] people to do it because they
don't get along with each other like
when Obama went into office evidently
all the Republicans on the first [ __ ]
day in the House the Senate or whatever
just basically said we are just going to
disagree with it we're not going to pass
anything that this guy says which is
really [ __ ] treasonous behavior I
think not saying you got to pass
everything the guy says you do have to
keep him in check but before it even
comes down the pipe you're saying we're
not going to [ __ ] work with this guy
I don't know
so but you can't ever expect these
[ __ ] to ever get along they act like
a bunch of [ __ ] babies they really
are a bunch of babies the way that they
behave so but that doesn't mean you have
to [ __ ] behave like that you know you
could be you could be that person who
doesn't scream and yell you be that
person that doesn't talk down to
somebody because they don't live near an
ocean or you could not judge somebody
because they do live near the ocean for
whatever [ __ ] reason the blue states
are near the ocean the other ones are
[ __ ] in the middle and everybody's
screaming and yelling each other I have
gone to all 50 states and goddamn it
I've met great people out there
I really have great food great fun you
know quit [ __ ] yelling at everybody
and now you're going to be alright
Trump's going to be President for a lot
of people I guess there'll be a good
thing for other people it's not going to
be a good thing but you know what you're
not going to die okay get out in front
of it think something positive the end
of the day if you want to get your
business going you're still going to
have to do it even if Obama was still in
office a Hillary got there a [ __ ]
Newt Gingrich or Rudy Giuliani the end
of the day your life is on you and life
is not fair
and people don't have the time to give a
[ __ ] you know and that's how it is it's
unfortunate but that is how it is but
the second you [ __ ] address that it's
kind of empowering right oh [ __ ] I got
to handle this [ __ ] you know and this is
coming from a privileged white male so
Oh go [ __ ] yourselves
all right that's that's it okay um you
just try to say [ __ ] posit people oh
what if this happens all right well then
quit quit move to [ __ ] Canada with
Cher see if anybody gives a [ __ ] um
anyways uh here comes some music I guess
is what happens now and then we'll get
to listen to some Greatest Hits
before uh the orange toupee guy was he
made possibly even running for president
who knows hey who do you think's he you
know he should pick another reality TV
show star for his [ __ ] vice
presidency
you know he should get the guy from
Survivor you know who gets progressively
angrier with every [ __ ] season I
don't if you guys have noticed that I
don't understand like I stopped watching
it years ago because of it he just like
you know red team falling behind they
got to step it up he just starts [ __ ]
yelling at him he used to just be they
used to be more exciting happy I think
he's just sick of being out on that
Island watching people eating bugs I
don't know what his issue is but he
seems to be taking it out on the people
there in the island
you know as they waste away all right
I'm done babbling all right God have a
great weekend you [ __ ] and I'll see you
on Monday
see
hey what's going on it's bill burr is
the Monday morning podcast - what
happened yesterday man I'll tell you I
was in what the hell was I Fort Collins
Colorado I was performing at Colorado
State University and I was going to do
the podcast from there but every time I
went to call up I couldn't get service
so that's what happened and right now I
am in Indianapolis because I'm doing Bob
and Tom radio tomorrow morning to hide
my gig in Nashville all right so I'm on
the road this week in fact earlier this
week I heard that I heard a commercial
you know that Johnny Cash song where
he's like I've been to Tupelo thumbs up
rattling off all these cities happen
everywhere man
and I literally yelled I said shut the
[ __ ] up Johnny Silva so bye all right so
a lot of [ __ ] people and not to
mention the [ __ ] cities he mentioned
in that song are just a bunch of cities
you wouldn't want to go to anyways you
haven't been any everywhere you [ __ ]
redneck you should have said I've been
to Paris London you know I'm saying Rome
places people want to go not till below
Toledo Charles Town nobody gives a [ __ ]
and what did you do that
Johnny maybe that's why you were so
[ __ ] angry that's why I'm so [ __ ]
angry is that better those goddamn
cities - when it you know I like a
bottom let's let's turn it around here
make a little more positive as I go in
the 70s trying to figure out where the
[ __ ] up there we go
there we go um you know I like about
them use their they don't have enough
money to redo that downtown area so you
get to see what you know you know
America used to look like like 50 years
ago and I'm not trying to be
condescending here I actually liked it
architecture was better you know stuff
was made out of brick everything wasn't
like a [ __ ] Cheesecake Factory
Applebee's every time that's happened to
me in my life I've been on the road
hey go down the front desk do you have
any place where I can get something
healthy to eat um we have an apple base
that's a solution he wants something
healthy um what's healthy well you know
what healthy is healthy is when they
wrap the silverware in a napkin that
means you're eating healthy and you know
where they do that they do it at Appleby
they do what it Shoney's do it Joanie's
I've never um never eaten there at
Shoney's this certain rest [ __ ]
restaurant you just go by those chains
and for me anyways let me not speak for
you I don't be arrogant here but for me
anyway some certain restaurants fast
food chains
I literally just look at the sign and it
gives me a stomachache and I can never
eat there and Shoney's is one of them
Steak and Shake is another one of the
two of them I don't know mmm combined
and they have like this orange [ __ ]
sign that just it just reminds me of
what I'm going to feel like after I eat
that [ __ ] food but I'm not always right
cuz I got to tell you I avoided the
Waffle House like the plague for like a
decade on the road I would just see that
yellow sign with those just that regular
type script Waffle House and it just you
know you could just drive invite you
knew how sticky the [ __ ] tables were
going to be how toothless the waitress
was going to be how many felonies
how many convicted felons were going to
be is just it just wasn't worth it to
get [ __ ] waffles not to mention I have
a great recipe for waffles ah but then
you know what I did the rich [ __ ] tour
and the two guys I was on tour with on
the Chappelle show one night so let's go
to the waffles and I went in there and
you know wasn't that bad although I
gotta admit that spent so long since
I've been there whatever they have their
home fries smothered covered and all
that stuff with it's [ __ ] gross
you know I don't like you I don't mind
you your punching up the food a little
bit or kicking it up a notch and said uh
sensei Harold Carmichael why the [ __ ]
did his name pop what's that guy's name
Emilio Emilio Estevez was named in that
Chef when he goes BAM he closed the
sugar and everybody goes [ __ ] crazy
Emilio
Elias I think the cellphone is affecting
my [ __ ] memory what is his name Jesus
Christ uh Emeril there we go
Emeril Lagasse [ __ ] the worst you know I
was trying to remember the name screech
yesterday from Saved by the Bell because
I was talking about people being able to
sell tickets I couldn't [ __ ] remember
his name I was like scratchy Skippy
Sebastian I knew began with an S some
sort of hard consonant afterwards
screech okay what would you do if you
the parent of a child star
you know besides steal his money before
he turned 18 what what the [ __ ] would
you do especially if I mean uh I'll give
screeches parents a break okay but I
gotta say from here on out if you put
your kid into show business first of all
you're [ __ ] in the head
all right you wanted to make it on some
level all right and secondly if the kid
books the show and his characters his
character's name is like zippy or you
know just something you wouldn't name a
[ __ ] ferret if that's what his
character's name is yes breckel you just
know he's going to be a [ __ ] up I wanted
I say hurtful that he's not a [ __ ] up
you know I'm saying that point you got
to stick that kid in drug counseling you
know when he still eight years old
you know oh my god you know what that
would be a great [ __ ] show you could
have scared straight for child stars
what you do is you have whoever the next
[ __ ] Hannah Montana is right that's
another one you [ __ ] name rhymes you
finished she's gonna be on coke on her
knees in the bathroom of the Viper Room
within three years oh wait a minute but
her dad's Billy Ray Cyrus so he knows
he's been there he stopped in there baby
okay you understand look at my eyes look
at see the pain that is the pain of of
having a mullet and singing a song
called Achy Breaky Heart I swear to God
no it was not for five-year-old though
it wasn't it was for adults who is for
adults and they [ __ ] loved it and
they bought it and then one day they
figured out it sucked and then they all
acted like they never bought it and no
one ever come to my shows again so I cut
off my mullet and I impregnated your
momma and then we had you announced your
[ __ ] turn to continue the legacy of
horrific [ __ ] moments in show
business also this is the show you
basically have former child stars who've
done drugs that do from the courtship of
Eddie's father uh uh yep you have to do
Michael diamond
now Michael diamond key to the Beastie
Boys Dustin Diamond you have him [ __ ]
in there yeah you know you have random
Brady Bunch
but they never really did anything
[ __ ] [ __ ] and it really did anything
just other than linger around got a
boring cast of people whatever you just
take a bunch of child stars who [ __ ]
up who haven't died yet and then you
bring them in there and you haven't just
start screaming at whoever the next Earl
is to make sure he's not on drugs
and if I could somehow smooth it out I
think I could I could sell that show to
vh1 right stick the former rapper in
there get some hoes and you've got a
show so you might be asking yourself
bill you know you've been do
this podcast for quite a while you can
drive for quite a while on at your hotel
yet I know I'm not because I don't know
I didn't want to spend the night in
Indianapolis even though I have to do
radio tomorrow at 6:00 in the morning I
looked up I saw that the Red Wings are
playing the [ __ ] Pittsburgh Penguins
up in Detroit the best two teams in the
NHL last year I figure [ __ ] it I'll
drive up the street it can't be more
than an hour and a half Detroit well
turns out it's three hours and I already
had a [ __ ] car so joke's on me this
better be a good [ __ ] game but
anyways I'm driving along here so I
don't have the questions I don't have
the question so all I can do is just run
my [ __ ] mouth
this week which I have done for 9
minutes and 51 seconds but that also
includes the intro so I talk to the
[ __ ] machine every week alright so
this is that is a Waffle House now I'm
driving down the road and I'm trying to
make the decision the decision that
Americans have to make every day in this
country how do I not become a fat [ __ ]
I'm Italia it's very difficult out here
it's very difficult where can I eat at
here there's a place called Joe's
there's a throwback what is this place
Joe's Joe's Crab Shack oh yeah that's
what I do when I go to the middle of the
country let me order some seafood sure
that's fresh the [ __ ] is wrong with you
okay you know we're doing Indianapolis
we like sushi we love it oh yeah what
kind of sushi do you have trout sushi so
sort of fresh they have catfish sushi
out here we just go down there we just
we just pull it out of the creek why
does every [ __ ] in my act have a
southern accent I really have to stop
that I'll tell you why because everytime
you get outside of a major city
everybody [ __ ] talks like that
everybody's got a little bit of lazy
lazy way of speaking
look at those awful apartments every
[ __ ] one looking the same but it's
right near a man-made lake I got to tell
you
most depressing things ever for me oh
that's nice we just merge down to two
lanes for this signs maybe if I wasn't
doing the podcast can you imagine if I
actually caused one of those horrific
highway accidents you know like you
anybody used to watch that show chips
remember that Erik Estrada Larry Wilcox
bastard it just didn't happen and he's
had them driving down the street of
their motorcycles and wants to show they
would literally have a twenty to thirty
car pileup which in all my years of
being on the road I have never [ __ ]
seen and my favorite thing about those
pileups right was they would last for
like a good [ __ ] I don't know one
minute on television which basically in
real life is like a five minute
catastrophe and everything when
everything was all said and done there's
like twenty five cars
upside down twisted around it was always
like an olive oil tanker and then there
was always that last guy
the last guy would always somehow he'd
get air off of cars rather than just
plowing into them he just defy he would
defy physics and he would somehow get
air shoot up and over everybody and if
you listen to the audio for some reason
the guy would still be hitting the gas
he's literally in the air and his car is
still going on like he thinks he's gonna
make it over I never understood that
even as a little boy a little lad
watching it and I'd look at my dad and I
would say dad why did he do that and
he'd be like shut the [ __ ] up son you
shut the [ __ ] up
and then the cat's in the cradle and the
state of a mu silver spoon there it is
I'm telling you I think the [ __ ] cell
phone is affecting my memory so anyway
let's talk conspiracy theory hey
everybody how about that seven hundred
million dollar bailout is that awesome
as Anna made the country a lot better
these [ __ ] [ __ ] you know I
realized after New Year's you know the
al Qaeda is it's the goddamn bankers
cannot I mean them more [ __ ]
terrorists than anybody these sons of
[ __ ]
know what they're doing that money as a
lowered interest rates so people can get
alone [ __ ] no gm's going under you know
what they're doing with the money from
what I overheard on the radio is they're
they're using it to buy up other failing
banks just inching us towards the one
world bank that's what they're using it
for and they have the audacity to raise
the interest rates on credit cards to
help pay for this mortgage mess then we
just give you 700 billion dollars to get
you out of it
I didn't know you were going to keep it
so you could buy more assets and then
further [ __ ] me in the ass it's up to 27
percent on some people's cards don't
they have some sort of usury laws does
anybody who's remotely I want to say
majored in economics does anybody who
understands this at what point what what
what percentage is usury they're up to
27 percent I mean back in the day did
did the mob even do that they all
everybody that's what I realized when I
really looked at the whole economy net
broken everything down and I realized
all the money I've made in this business
how much of it I've I ever held in my
hand you know I take out 100 bucks here
100 bucks there I pay everything for the
check I get paid and check six numbers
on a piece of paper and I kind of
realized that even if I own [ __ ] it can
still be seized with the Patriot Act I
can be arrested not charged and [ __ ]
waterboarded you know I realize I'm
going to grow a mustache just in case
everything waterboarded
you know it's like they're still going
to slowly drown me but take water going
up my nose it's going to grow in those
big [ __ ] 1970s sex symbol mustaches
you know Burt Reynolds he knows that the
best mustache you ever and of course I
don't know his name he's a guy who was
in them he was actually in the big
lebowski he was a narrator Sam Elliott I
mean that guy's mustache
it's [ __ ] ridiculous someone a
mustache wasn't cool for like 20 years
but he kept his his was so [ __ ] cool
you couldn't question his mustache yeah
that's like a man that's like a [ __ ]
panning for gold in the 1840s selling
the gold rush was anybody listen to this
from San Francisco and you went out
there and you're saying those awful
[ __ ] songs Oh m'darlin Oh m'darlin Oh
m'darlin Clementine you got the worst
[ __ ] name in the world you must be
you know the [ __ ] is there ever been a
good-looking woman named Clementine you
notice that there's like hot girl names
like Natasha I've never seen an ugly
girl named Natasha yet I've never seen a
cool girl named Natasha I always just
see some hot girl who no she's [ __ ]
hot at 8 because her name is Natasha
which ends up making to be really um a
[ __ ] be honest with you or is it more
about me that I never had the courage to
approach a girl named Natasha Natasha
sexy a Brooke that's a good one Brooke
Natasha not Melissa
Melissa's can kind of be down-to-earth
there's some sort of offshoot of Melissa
I always notice what the [ __ ] I don't
know
Jesus Christ is it depressing out here
it is absolutely overcast I'll tell you
the Midwest Midwestern in the summertime
when all the crops you know I'm waving
in the air you know makes you proud to
be an American but when you're out here
the beginning of winter you start to
understand crystal meth I get it now I
understand the anger of split not I
never understood those guys like [ __ ]
so angry about and then I was in Iowa in
like February and I was like you know
what I get it I get it it's like I don't
know it really [ __ ] affects your move
this is awful those guys looking for
guys on the side of the road they're not
well guys if you're on the side of the
road you're not picking up litter you
know you're not mowing the grass you're
not waiting to give somebody a ticket
but you still got a little shine a
little [ __ ] siren on top of you car
it's the neutral one not that orange one
it's like the it's like the Jan Brady of
emergency vehicles oh look at that a
Super eight motel with an indoor pool
huh who says this country thin top is in
trouble
wow they really really stepped it up
they're finally living up to that name
super right it was never super when I
went to it there's a snake in shake next
exit oh this is this part of the country
who knows you who don't travel this is
Steak and Shake Dairy Queen country
Heartland Resort camping do you know I
had an I had a chance to go skeet
shooting in DC I got so [ __ ] drunk
with Joe DeRosa the night before I
couldn't do it me and Joe DeRosa the guy
I do uninformed with we are not good for
each other that's what I realized when I
think when we're by ourselves we can
make good decisions but when we are
hanging out together every once you've
got a friend like that where after a
while you know you just have to kind of
tap out I'm not saying I'm not going to
be friends with Joe
rose anymore I just I don't know if I I
don't think I can hang out with them
anymore
why are you driving so [ __ ] slow in
the left lane with your high performance
muffler those high performance mufflers
the ridiculous didn't somebody send
something in about those being overrated
do those fool little asian girls into
thinking that you have a fast car I
actually think it's an old guy with
white hair or is that a baseball cap
basically a Honda Civic early 90s with a
with a hatchback it looks like he's got
some sort of erector set suspension and
you never that [ __ ] memory erectus that
aspect one needs to give you toys to try
to make you smart and give like a
chemistry set can you hear that
can you hear his car wah wah wah wah wah
look doing [ __ ] 65 and he sounds like
a motorcycle off in the distance and
he's really [ __ ] thirty yards in
front of me system physics major out
there doing the math right now to see if
I'm not following too closely behind all
right so we're up to 20 minutes that's
not bad that's not bad I know is how I
used to do like an old school one
throwback a [ __ ] throwback I'm uh I'm
really going to be hating this drive
when I come back do you realize that I'm
such a mate why doesn't this guy have a
side view mirror okay here we go I'm
driving by him and it is uh you know
what it was a younger kid and he had one
of those you know the goatee where you
don't have the mustache but then you
have like the really long [ __ ] hanging
off your chin it basically says you know
I'm not wearing a condom I don't know
anyways let's heighten my kicks up
coming this week okay if you've enjoyed
this podcast and you have a radio I will
be on the Bob and Tom show tomorrow
morning all across this great country of
ours which is feel great if we could get
rid of these [ __ ] bankers and
I'm going to be hyping my upcoming
the next gig on the uninformed tour in
Zanies in Nashville Tennessee on this
Thursday Friday and Saturday me and Joe
DeRosa two-man show we're going to be
telling some jokes or whatever and if
you came and saw me last year I wrote a
whole new our people in Nashville and
listen to this I want to go skeet
shooting
I blew it in DC I want to go I want to
learn how to shoot something that's my
next puck and move as I plan for the New
World Order so come on man I'm going
down to Nashville I know it's the Music
City capital of the world but god damn
it
just outside of it I know there's a
bunch of people with guns and they got
fields and I want to go out there and
shoot little clay discs so why don't you
hook me up I got I got it here you go
anybody who looks me up take me out goes
skeet shooting gets up free three three
three DVDs say that ten times fast
for you your buddy you go hunting with
and your best girlfriend with them daisy
dukes [ __ ] I'm serious
I want to I want to learn okay hey is
his his my latest [ __ ] conspiracy
that I know they're going to combine
this country with [ __ ] Mexico and
with Canada aside from the fact that
they got that creepy commercial about
how they have a new enhanced driver's
license that'll make it easier to travel
between the United States Canada and
Mexico personally I didn't know that was
a problem I don't know those people
around there go you know I love this
country but I just wish it was easier to
go to Canada god damn it if I could just
go to Mexico a little bit earlier I mean
easier this is my big conspiracy I've
noticed lately I'm traveling in airports
and all of a sudden there's this new
software out there called rosetta stone
which is that damnit I wish I looked it
up I don't know the rosetta stone is
some sort of why do I know what the [ __ ]
it is it's something biblical is it like
the Hope Diamond I don't know what it is
but basically they took that name and it
is now a software that teaches you a
bunch of different languages
okay which I always thought was cool I
want to learn another language but
nobody in America has ever given a [ __ ]
now all of a sudden they're selling
these [ __ ] things I was just getting
off at the airport I can see if you're
in New York if you're in Los honglei's
we can actually speak Spanish every
[ __ ] three feet I get it
for maybe French or something like that
I don't know but like I just got off it
I the airport here in Indianapolis and
they selling the rosetta stone software
what a [ __ ] in Indianapolis his clamor
and to learn a different language I'd
you know something's going on they're
putting it in your head I'm telling if
you stick it around stick it out front
of people long enough that it's like
Rubik's cubes when you really think
about it was that thing fun it was kind
of like a toy that was fixed and you
spun it three times and then it was
broken and you can never get it fixed
again unless you had an Asian front so
for some reason figured out how to do it
I don't know what it is about those guys
they just [ __ ] smarter than us is
that like reverse racist in a way it
actually said something [ __ ] are you
allowed to do that I know you're not
allowed to say something bad straight
across about a race of people can I say
something good you know the politically
correct police going to come at me now
that's just as bad because that's
offensive to stupid Asian people it's
going to make them feel even more
[ __ ] and we don't want that
anyways Wow
I am really out here in the heartland
right now you know something people
always say like that's the movement
start a farm start a farm save your
money in that type of [ __ ] but as far as
I can tell these farmers are [ __ ] to
putting it because they only grow one
crop so what are you going to do you're
going to grow [ __ ] corn you know all
right you grow corn then everything goes
down you can't afford food even if you
got well water on you on your [ __ ]
property when you get corn every [ __ ]
day some point you can I guess maybe you
can go out and shoot a pheasant you know
those runs
okay used to waiting at the hall-of-fame
any of Indiana Basketball Hall of Fame
get the [ __ ] out of here Jesus Christ
that's gonna be the big biggest
collection of white basketball players
with booty shorts in the goddamn country
and you know Larry birdie said Jesus and
I can't argue with them Larry Bird now
there is it was it was an awful mustache
he I have a cleft palate mustache
ah Jesus that was me but you know what
actually bought one of those kids a new
smile so I'm able to do that joke Larry
Bird had a a [ __ ] fourteen-year-old
white-trash mustache when he was like 28
I don't think it ever filled in his
entire career that awful oval face but
goddamn it he could play he could
definitely play look at me trash one of
the icons a bus but it would have
thought anyways I'm going to end this
podcast this week with uh what the joke
I used to do back in my college days is
back in college this is what I wanted to
do all the my college gigs stand-up gigs
back before I was doing mainly clubs
I used to land at the airport so I get a
run a car you know grab a couple of CDs
possibly cassette tapes depending on
what point in my career and I Drive
across you know the farmlands out here
in the Midwest and I ended up getting a
joke out of it and this was the joke
that was like you know every time you
see farmers on the news you know we see
in bitching about how difficult farming
is you know what I must've driven by ten
thousand farms during my stand-up career
and you know what I've never seen
anybody doing [ __ ] the tractors always
parked cows and standing around there's
absolutely no [ __ ] activity
whatsoever and there's always a big
satellite dish they're in there watching
[ __ ] ESPN and then when the media
comes by and you just smear a bunch of
dirt on their face and like oh my god
there was a typhoon jump when something
like that and you know what today is no
different I just drove like 40 farms I
have not seen one [ __ ] person the
lights aren't even on
and then nappin oh I don't know what
they do this time of year all the crops
are cut down all the [ __ ] knows anyways
here's something out for all the people
on myspace I would really appreciate it
if you would go on to my website
billboard.com
and sign up for my mailing list because
I'm sort of inching my way over to that
one more so than the myspace I'll still
put [ __ ] up on myspace but uh I plan to
start blogging and all that crap once I
get done with this uninformed tour a lot
of putting some extras on there because
you know I haven't joined Facebook yet I
just really don't feel like going over
to Facebook and have to add the same
30,000 [ __ ] people that I already
have so if you go to my website then you
know what I mean
and I won't spam you and plus you're
also able to control what sort of emails
you get for me like when I said I was
going at Nashville I just emailed people
on my Nashville list okay so you're not
going to get [ __ ] updates for me
every week is I have some sort of zany
picture trying to utilize the web this
is my one once a week thing that i do
which i think is a good thing
okay i usually do it on mondays i [ __ ]
around
i give you a [ __ ] free audio show
alright a lot more than that some of
these other concepts are doing right
alright that's it that's the Monday
morning podcast on a Tuesday I apologize
I didn't get any cell phone service so
god bless alia god bless the United
States of America
[ __ ] the bankers please go on the
internet and start reading about banking
please read about it and just read what
a [ __ ] over it is and educate yourself
with conspiracy theory that is based in
Wikipedia and YouTube videos that's not
it's not all bad everybody I don't like
just font telling you man I don't like
internet internet gets a bad rap I don't
like they I like everything on the
internet a lie but TV is telling you the
truth
think about the insanity of that man
that's [ __ ] ridiculous they're both
full of [ __ ] and so am i selling [ __ ]
listen to me have a good week and I
please if you live anywhere near
Nashville please come down come out and
see me um
and that is it that's it all right
everybody have a good week I said that
15 times god dammit but I want you know
I really mean it I hope you have a great
week
all right god bless take it
Oh
you